okay let's go over some Modern action
flick Essentials menacing bad guys check
Jason Statham kicking butt and spouting
clever onliners check a ton of bees
check wait what yep The Beekeeper is in
theaters on January 12th and it's full
of all you could want from an action
thriller plus you know all the bees this
movie is getting so much Buzz hey now
that I decided to take a look at some
behind the scenes action from it it
probably won't surprise you to learn
that Jason state gets sent a lot of
scripts after all when it comes to
action Stars he's as close to a lock As
It Gets In terms of box office success
so it takes a lot for a script to get to
the top of the giant piles in his office
I'm imagining his office also has a gym
in it but maybe that's just me but
apparently the choice to make The
Beekeeper was a pretty easy one in an
interview Jason talked about how he had
a longtime connection to writer Kurt
Wimmer but somehow they had never
managed to find a project to work on
together scripts that we nearly did
scripts that we didn't do we haven't
sort of done anything and it was it an
opportune moment where we connected and
he passed me something slipped it to me
and I can assume Jason was probably
thinking that this would be just another
script from Kurt that didn't work out
but it quickly became evident that
something was different this time I
literally it was a page Turner for me I
was so excited I said we just got to do
this and we'll team up and we'll we'll
make this happen very quickly Stam also
loves the fact that it's not your
standard action movie he admits that it
does have elements of good modern action
movies that will make it a hit for
Action fans it's quite dark and it's a
thriller and it has lots of things that
can shock and keep you know the action
fans on the edge of their seats but he
also feels that there are elements to
the movie that give it a universal
appeal it does have a very strong sort
of a a very strong sort of meaning about
right and wrong it's about people that
are vulnerable getting taken advantage
of he was able to take it to the con
Film Festival where he was pleasantly
surprised at how much it resonated with
more than just the action fans there so
why does this movie resonate with so
many people in other words what's it
about glad you asked Stam plays Adam
clay who lives a quiet Life as a rural
beekeeper he looks after his hives and
is a great neighbor to an older lady
named Eloise sadly Eloise Falls victim
to an online scam and loses a bunch of
money and even more tragically she kills
herself because of it we see that
there's a massive operation of criminals
who entire business plan is to fool
elderly people into giving their money
away and as you probably know this is
something that is happening more and
more in real life so as you might expect
Statham's character decides it's time to
take this organization out not only to
avenge his friend but also to stop them
from scamming other innocent people and
the rest is a back and forth of him
being a badass and trying to stomp out
the
evildoers and while it's always fun to
see Jason kicking but you might might be
wondering why they chose his hobby as
beekeeping we meet him he's at the
beginning of the film and he's a retired
sort of guy that just connecting with
something that he has a love for which
is making honey well it turns out the
beekeepers are an elite unit authorized
by the government to quote protect the
hive I'm sure the movie goes into more
detail but that's what you should know
so far even in this interview Jason
keeps his cards close to the vest about
what they do his actual title of being a
beekeeper which we find out later on
what the real version of a beekeeper is
when we come to this sort of
governmental kind of special Society of
course even the man playing the Super
Soldier is pretty much a badass too in
an interview with the sight bleeding
cool director David AER revealed that
Statham insisted on doing all of his
stunts that involved the bees and TBH
that takes a different kind of Bravery
than driving a stunt car or jumping off
buildings but amazingly according to a
Statham didn't get stung once a added
quote I I got stung pretty bad shooting
bees later on but it was fine you make a
movie called The Beekeeper you're going
to get stung beyond the fun of an action
movie about a man out for vengeance
Jason and his co-stars feel like it's an
important story to tell he talks about
how scamming the elderly is rampant
these days and it's something that
doesn't get talked about enough people
don't know how to deal with those things
especially the elderly and the elderly
are the people that they target because
they kind of they live solitary lives
and worst of all says Jason there's not
enough Justice for these people their
life savings go down the pan everything
gets you know siphoned out and there's
no accountability for this it just goes
on and it's U it's a terrible terrible
thing that happens in society it's not
just Statham who feels this way his
co-star Josh Hutcherson was at first
equally intrigued by the blend of action
and odity is it's like an epic Vengeance
story about a guy who has a very
peculiar set of skills he keeps bees
which is very weird but when he got deep
ER into the script and the film he
realized how it was much bigger so it's
a story of of searching for justice and
really like what does justice mean and
how that looks for different people's
perspectives but it didn't stop there
for Josh he has a much more personal
connection to the story his great
grandmother was a victim of a similar
type of scam she was told by scammers
that his cousin was in trouble and she
bought a bunch of Apple gift cards and
gave the codes on them to the scammers
Josh of course felt awful about this
it's evil man it's evil and like my
grandma's such a sweet woman and like
she wants to help everybody but is
susceptible in ways co-star Felicia
Rashad was drawn to the movie for
similar reasons she talks about how
these scammers sound personable but are
terrible people they try to sound so
friendly and they're so personal and so
personable and they're just thieves they
are thieves you know so this is what
attracted me to it and I'm sure the rest
of the cast which includes the
inimitable Jeremy Irons mini driver and
Emmy raver Lampman were drawn to similar
aspects of the story that and the chance
to be a part of a Jason STM action flick
so are you as psyched as I am to see
this one or rather could I be any more
psyched to see it sorry I had to get at
least one more bbased pun out of my
system we can't have me shouting bad
jokes at the theater screen people have
any thoughts about Jason Statham and The
Beekeeper pop them in the comment
section
below